[Musique]
une image de la province non une vision
qui permet encore à paris de garder son
charme si particulier si envié dans le
monde entier et pourtant tout ne va pas
pour le mieux parmi les fleuristes du
célèbre marché aux fleurs de la cité
écoutons madame ben terre fondatrice du
comité de défense de ce marché
l'emplacement du marché et a donc été
fait sous blanche de castille pour y
vendre des fleurs et des plantes des
légumes enfin comme on vendait à ce
moment là c'était ce qui correspond aux
petits crainquebille actuelle et puis
alors petit à petit ça s'est transformé
le marché est entré dans le domaine
public puisque nous sommes locataires de
la ville de paris et le marché est resté
tel que vous le voyez aujourd'hui je
souhaiterais que ce soit un peu plus
proches quand même
koné on a de très jolies fleurs c'est
très joli c'est très accueillant mais
nous avons les voitures qui sont
vraiment minable c'est à dire c'est à
dire il faudrait que les repeindre
lestoille et faire un bon nettoyage oui
et
et pour nous ce serait bien plus joli
petit coup de peinture un petit coup de
peinture oui ce serait si facile de le
faire
qu'ils nous laissent faire qui vont les
suivre le panneau même heureusement
pourrait-on penser ici des mesures sont
prises pour faciliter la circulation et
le stationnement
hélas la situation est bien différente
nous avons obtenu par décret préfectoral
une année qui sert de parking pour nos
clients et une autre à l'est qui est en
principe réservée pour nos voitures
personnelles et celles de nos
fournisseurs mais bien entendu il
faudrait en permanence des agents que
nous nous notre enfance transformer en
gendarme parce que vraiment ça n'est pas
observée alors on reste toujours avec
notre même problème il est d'autres
problèmes qui trouble la sérénité des
paisibles fleuriste tous les soirs il ya
des vols et la semaine dernière on nous
a volé sur place là trois jardins
japonais qui représentait quand même une
certaine valeur
c'est désagréable on a fait une pétition
ci suivi je pense qu'il aura quand même
un résultat qui a évidemment le problème
général des supermarchés
bien sûr sont des magasins patente
multiples ils vendent de tout ils sont
autorisés
on peut pas dire c'est tout de même une
concurrence c'est certain
quoique nous notre marché ici c'est tout
de même un petit peu à part le client
qui vient nous voir petrou trouver des
fleurs coupées des plantes d'appartement
des petites plantes pour les balcons ont
fait les plantations fait des terrasses
enfin on est tout de même un centre
important puisque on doit être à peu
près une cinquantaine de commerçants
mais quel est l'avenir de cette
cinquantaine de fleuriste l'incertitude
et l'inquiétude règne
écoutez nous avons sur le marché depuis
quelques temps quantité de cessation
d'activité des gens qui arrêtent
simplement de travailler des décès saran
des places vacantes et nous sommes très
mal très ému c'est le club de tir parce
que ces places là ne sont pardonnés
alors nous nous posons la question
est ce que vraiment le marché aux fleurs
va continuer à voir son activité
ou alors est-ce qu'il cessera par faute
de titulaire
[Musique]